Here are a few diagrams representing
the difference between hardware pixels
and dips.
The blue grid represents
a grid of hardware pixels.
So, one pixel, two, three,
four, five, six, et cetera.
And then, the single orange
square represents a single dip.
So in this diagram,
a dip takes up this much space,
of the hardware pixels,
in this case it takes this much.
In this case it takes up this
much of the hardware pixels,
in here it only takes
up one hardware pixel.
So which of these diagrams represents
a device pixel ratio of two.
Remember, the device pixel
ratio compares the number of
pixels in just one dimension, not two.
So think one dimension.